malgré sa petite taille et ses 630
habitants le village de janvry est connu
pour son charme et ses nombreux
événements comme le bar de la plage qui
tous les étés depuis 20 ans transforme
la petite ferme de janvry en un bord de
mer au coeur de la vallée de chevreuse
la plus ferme de jean brice est un peu
la ferme au mieux le visage on fait tous
nos événements tout au long de l'année
et pendant tout le temps de l'été c'est
200 tonnes de sable une piscine zodiac
40 tonnes d'eau des paliers des jeunes
hommes et des jeunes filles en maillot
de bain des boissons pas cher tout ça
pour les adhérents de l'association et
l'adhésion 5 euros pour toute l'année et
donc du coup toute la saison plage sans
compter le reste des activités
on a un flux de visiteurs de deux
touristes même un peu jamais vu qui fait
qu' on a battu tous les records de des
meilleures saisons à la mi saison je
dirais qu'il ya pas de profil type ccd
gens qui viennent ici trouver un petit
oasis qui ne peuvent pas partir en
vacances reviennent de vacances n'ont
pas de vacances et sort du travail et
qui viennent ici avoir une petite
bouffée d'air pur c'est donc tous les
jours de 11 heures à 19 heures que les
visiteurs peuvent profiter de ce lieu et
de ses diverses activités proposées via
la piscine la grande évidemment pour les
petits et les grands à la piscine pour
les petits et jouets pour le sable deux
tables de ping pong un baby foot on
prête le matériel nécessaire même si on
se baigne pas déjà aulas le genre il
arrive au début un petit peu étonnés ils
repartent avec le sourire et y
reviennent le lendemain un événement
très populaire qui permet également aux
jeunes de la région de trouver un
travail d'été très formateur
c'est une vingtaine d'emplois qui sont
créées qui permettent aux jeunes de
janvry et des environs aussi parce qu'on
n'est pas on n'est pas sectaires de se
faire une première un professionnel il
gagne un petit pécule pour pouvoir
partir en vacances notamment janvry est
véritablement promoteurs de toute idée
neuve oublier parfois avant gardiste
pour proposer justement des solutions
aux gens pour sortir de chez eux se
rencontrent et passer un bon moment
un bon moment tu les deux mille trois
cent cinquante adhérents du mois de
juillet ont grandement apprécié un
chiffre record qui illustre bien la
devise du village
l'art de mieux vivre ensemble